the battle at Wolf
359 decimated
Starfleet but did it in the end actually
save the entire
Federation we are the Borg lower your
Shields and surrender your ships we will
add your biological and technological
distinctiveness to our own your culture
will adapt to service us resistance is
fule welcome to sidere your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel in 236 7 in stard date
42.3 in the wolf system there was a
battle between Starfleet and a single
Bor Cube 40 vessels stood up against
that invading vessel and 39 were
destroyed this sent shock waves through
the Federation not just because it was
the worst defeat the Federation and
Starfleet had suffered since the Klingon
War but more importantly
at the ease of their defeat the Borg
barely even slowed down and completely
wiped out 39 vessels nearly destroying
the 40th Without Really breaking a
sweat and this was an encounter that the
Federation had known about for 18 months
before they had been preparing for this
and their preparations were very very
quickly shown to not really be worth
much so why do I say that this battle
one of the worst single defeats in sta
Le's history went on to save the
Federation well first of all we got to
remember the time frame of the Next
Generation it was really the Golden Age
of Starfleet when the Galaxy class
Enterprise NCC
171d was commissioned she had families
aboard she was really a flying City City
in lots of ways with vast internal
spaces entertainment centers several
Hollow decks etc etc she was not really
particularly well armed compared to
other vessels say like a Romulan bird of
prey she was not particularly well
defended as we saw several times she was
an allround vessel really designed with
exploration in mind the fact that they
had families on board the Enterprise
really tells us everything we need to
know about the mindset of the Federation
and Starfleet at the time they were
enjoying a period of relative peace and
confidence their Alliance following the
Kitt records with the Klingons meant
that the federation's only real main
adversary the romulans was really under
their thumb the Klingons were really
violent and Military and the Federation
always had that stick ready if there has
ever been a conflict with the romulans
at this period the Klingons would have
been the federation's ace up their
sleeve they would have been able to use
the Klingons for some of the bloodier
battles and even though the Romulus had
a very powerful Fleet it would not have
been able to stand against the combined
might of the Federation and the Klingon
fleets I think this put the Federation
in a state of complacency a complacency
that was shattered by wolf
359 so what was the reaction by
Starfleet well one thing they started to
do is to develop the defiant Class A
Mighty little ship that proved itself in
combat over and over again even though
following the defeat of the Borg there
was again a period of somewhat
complacency running up to the Dominion
conflict and the def was maybe seen as
not as vital as it previously was there
was still though a massive development
program and a rebuilding of Fleet we saw
new starships and the development of The
Sovereign class that would follow the
Enterprise D even things like the
development of the Intrepid class was a
direct response to the Borg Invasion now
the Enterprise D and the Enterprise E
even were multi-purpose vessels and
that's what Starfleet was made up of at
this time we had the smaller science
vessels but the bulk of the fleet was
these multi- capability Starships they
weren't really designed with any one
thing in mind the defiant though is a
change in philosophy she was a vessel
designed purely for conflict but then we
also got to see ships like the
Prometheus with its multi Vector Attack
Mode vessels that were designed with
combat in mind the prim primary reason
for her construction was Battle and when
the dominions War started the Federation
must have been thanking their lucky
stars that all of this development work
and all of this construction of new
Starships had started because when the
Dominion came through the wormhole in
such numbers the Federation would not
have been ready if it wasn't for the
conflict with the Borg and the battle at
Wolf 35
you see the Dominion have the cunning of
the romulans the brutality of the
Klingons and the intelligence of the
Federation they were able to build
Starships faster than anyone could
imagine their vessels had technology
that the Federation couldn't at least
initially counter weapon fire that cut
straight through their Shields as if
they weren't there they were able to
create political alliances across the
alpha quadrant which put the Federation
on its back foot almost immediately
whereas the Borg were like a
sledgehammer the Dominion were an
allpurpose enemy and they were able to
fight the Federation in a multiple of
different ways they had dominated the
gamma quadrant for who knows how long
because they were able to fight in many
different ways they used Politics as a
weapon almost as freely as they used a
they were just as cunning as they were
brutal and that made them a terrifying
adversary for the Federation and the
entire Alpha quadrant as I said the
Federation and Starlet had been
constructing new vessels already and
developing new Starships things like the
defiant and the Prometheus don't get
built overnight the Dominion War started
6 years after the events at Wolf 359
that had given the Federation and sta
the opportunity to not only rebuild the
fleet but also to start the development
work on these new fighting vessels this
new philosophy as they were going out of
the golden age of peace and into a
period of almost constant conflict now
thanks to the cunning of the Dominion
the Klingons and Federation nearly went
into conflict themselves The Shape
Shifters were out there in the alpha
quadrant causing trouble well before
their Fleet ever arrived D it meant they
had a tactic of divide and conquer
between the Federation the Klingons and
it nearly worked so the Federation was
stood almost alone against the Dominion
for large sections of this war they
built new Starships as quickly as
possible but they amassed fleets of
hundreds of Starships really quickly
remembering that they could only amass a
fleet of 40 at Wolf
359 now obviously the Federation and AET
had a little bit more time to prepare
rather than one ball Cube coming
straight at them they knew this conflict
was coming for a couple of years and
were able to start building those
vessels but if it wasn't for the Lessons
Learned at w 359 about how weak star
fleet was against an enemy like this
those preparations wouldn't have started
and Starfleet would have had no chance
at all against the advancing hordes of
the Dominion so even though the battle
at Wolf 359 was devastating for the
Federation and for Starfleet if it
hadn't happened though the Dominion may
have walked straight into the Federation
and there would have been very very
little in their way I actually think
wolf 359 is the reason why the
Federation survived the Dominion War but
guys what do you think get into the
comments the Dominion really were in
lots of ways the Ultimate Enemy of the
Federation they even used the
federation's own tactics against them
they used diplomacy against them and to
defeat them the Federation didn't only
have to align itself with the Klingons
the romulans and anybody else that would
listen but they also had to then use
tactics that were not very
Federation get into the comments and
tell me what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification you'll never miss
any of our new videos and also go over
to patreon.com where most of our new
videos do premere first and you get to
see them without the adverts you lucky
bunnies also go over to
s.co where we do articles based on most
of our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
as always please stay safe and uh I'll
see you next time
computer erase that entire personal
[Music]
log